thanks for joining the typescript for
f-sharp zealots talk so this is an this
is a talk I'm doing that's not primarily
about f-sharp which might be a surprise
to some people watching this as many
people who have seen some talks from you
know I'm an f-sharp person but I thought
I'll speak about somewhat different
experience that I had had recently so I
couldn't find better illustration for
zealots than this meditating meditating
kitten but who definitely knows what's
the best programming language to use I
thought everybody needs a meditating
kitten in these days so this is going to
be a fairly opinionated talk and I'm
hoping that people will disagree with
some of the points and we can we can
sort of follow up in the in the comments
I'll be on slack as well if people have
have more things to say so why should
you why should you listen to this talk
I'm going to be talking about my
experience with using typescript for a
for one project that I've been working
on and I'll say a little bit about the
project first just so that you know what
kind of what kind of things are I've
been I've been doing what sort of
motivated the the talk and then I'll say
a few things about typescript and I'll
cover both the sort of the things that I
thought were nice about it coming from
an F sharp perspective and the things
that I thought were not so nice coming
from an EXOR perspective now I don't
really expect everybody to be an F sharp
zealot so the title of the thought was a
bit misleading I'll show you some some
relevant bits of F sharp code but it's
going to be fairly introductory so the
the thing I've been working working on
and this is this is a sort of project
that we've been doing using our base
have been using typescript
this system that I've been building in
collaboration with some people in the
Alan Turing Institute in London which is
trying to produce a new notebook system
for doing data science and it's it does
a few interesting things which I'll talk
about and the important bit is that
there's a client side that's fairly
non-trivial or does some interesting
things and that has been implemented in
in typescript so what does this actually
do there's a few things that make this
this project interesting first of all if
you're doing data science then these
days typically your entire sort of
workflow has to be in one language
typically Python or R we're doing
something where it's easy to mix
multiple languages in a single project
we're also doing quite a lot of clever
work to track dependencies between
different different bits of code in your
cysts in your code in your notebook so
that when you change something at the
beginning the things that are later on
get invalidated we want to be able to do
more in the browser so if you just sort
of join some interactive data
exploration that is something you should
be able to do straight in your web
browser and we have this feature called
AI assistants which are our clever tools
that help you with with some of the
common boring data wrangling problems so
you can actually try this yourself if
you go to rattler org we've got a button
which which will load an instance of the
system on someone else's computer in the
cloud so you can sort of experiment with
it quite easily and what you get is this
is this I'm going to make this a bit
bigger just so that it's easier to see
so you get the way the system works is
that it integrates with the standard
environment that data scientists use
called Jupiter so this is not really
a sort of stand-alone system altogether
it's it integrates with with what people
are already using and it adds a new kind
of notebook so this this this whole
thing that I'm scrolling through right
now this is actually the bit running the
bit of code that we wrote so it's is
hosting sort of standalone notebook
inside this the speaker IDE and I can do
various things so here's a sample in
Python where I'm just creating some
sample plot so I'm not really a data
scientist so I'm not going to tell you
much about data science I'm just going
to tell you about building tools for
data science now the more interesting
thing is here so what I'm doing here is
I've got a cell or code block written in
Python and what this does is that it
uses this under sly berry to read a CSV
file from github and it reads some
finance charts and then I can evaluate
that but following that I've got a
JavaScript code block that loads the
plotly data visualization library and
I've got a JavaScript code block that
exercise this
[Music]
AAPL data set that I load it in the
previous Python code block so the really
interesting thing here is I can mix
Python and JavaScript and if I run this
without any sort of explicit passing of
data between Python and JavaScript I'm
able to build nice interactive charts so
this is showing some finance data my
zooming skills are quite bad so that's
one thing we are doing
the other interesting thing is how does
the tracking between dependencies work
so in a typical data science system what
you get is you just have to run through
the code sort of from top to bottom and
if you miss something at the beginning
later on you'll get errors saying ah you
didn't run or a variable 1 is undefined
so this system does something more
clever where here I'm defining data sets
1 2 & 3 in JavaScript Python and in R
and then I have a bit of code on again
JavaScript Python and R that just
connects all these three data frames
together and if I try to run one of
those then it figures out that it has to
evaluate all these all these cells that
I had at the beginning so it does that
those create some data frames and then
it evaluates the one I clicked on but it
doesn't evaluate another sort of cell
that I had earlier in the notebook that
doesn't really where the current one
doesn't depend on it
so it does it does a bit of clever sort
of tracking to figure out what depends
on what and I can even visualize this so
we have this little visualizer where you
can see how the different bits of code
all depend on each other so there's
there some cells those are the bluish
markdown cells which are just code just
comments they don't depend on anything
but then
there's there's some are code some
Python code and some JavaScript code and
you can see that this depends on the
inputs and outputs depend on that so
this is what we've been what we've been
building and I just wanted to give you a
clear sort of quick quick demo of the
system itself so that you know what's
what's my what's my sort of background
where I'm coming from
so the client-side what I was sort of
playing with in the browser
that's all implemented in typescript and
as I admitted already
I'm an excerpt person so why did we end
up with typescript so this was this was
a project with a larger team we're more
more people in the team knew typescript
and that was one of the motivations and
I wasn't really working on this
full-time so it was it was quite
important so so that sort of work in a
way where others can be in control and
and do things even when I disappear for
a few weeks so that was one of the
reasons for choosing typescript the
other thing we thought was that the
Jupiter platform itself is implemented
in typescript so if we do the same thing
then maybe people might contribute a bit
more which is a nice nice idea in theory
in practice that actually doesn't happen
so getting outside contributors is
always difficult so what are what are
the sort of reflections on typescript
based on that project and this is again
this is sort of reflections coming from
an F sharp perspective so maybe it's
sort of interesting and not necessarily
a mainstream B you on typescript so
that's that's why I thought this was an
interesting thing to say the good thing
is that you can actually do fairly nice
functional programming in typescript or
you can use the sort of
elegant beautiful functional
architecture and I'll spent quite a bit
of time showing how that worked
the bet is that the typescript system
does make some difficult trade-offs in
the type system and this is this is
inevitable because that's how typescript
was designed it's sort of designed to
deal with full full JavaScript world so
you have to make those changes or make
those decisions there's nothing else
that could be done but it does make
certain certain functional programming
patterns quite annoying and one that I
found which I call 2d ugly here is you
would think that typescript has the sort
of simple simple JavaScript syntax but
that isn't really the case anymore so
I'll have a few complaints about syntax
it's not quite the what talk but you'll
see what what happens so I want to start
with the good things so that those of
you who are interested and like
typescript can watch the first step part
of the talk and then switch to some
other session if you don't want to hear
me rambling about the bad and ugly the
good thing so the way we structured our
system is we're using this Elm style
architecture and we've actually
implemented quite a lot of that
ourselves except for one monkey bit and
the reason and the nice thing in this
architecture is if you're using function
style you really just have two immutable
types representing the state the moral
and event what is happening in your in
your notebook and then you have two
functions update and render and they're
purely functional and our implementation
has very few dependencies the nice thing
about this model is that it's really
easy to debug and understand what's
going on and in a system that's fairly
interactive
we're sort of cells are evaluated in the
background and and stuff like that this
has been quite valuable so why why not
just use react and this is a question
that I think is is important because I'm
going to show you how to implement a few
things from scratch and I think this is
very often a sort of good approach if if
certain things are true so our a user
interface in the system it's not very
fancy like it's really just this page so
the fancy things here are well there's a
few buttons for like moving things
around we're using the Monaco editor
that's the only that's the only sort of
rich components that we need but we're
not building like complicated forms for
entering dates and stuff where react has
a lot of components so we don't really
need a lot of components the other thing
is that this is project that's been
going on for a few years
and it's sort of done at an academic
pace where you get back to it sort of
every every once in a while when you add
new things so it's not exactly great if
all your dependencies completely change
between every time you sort of get back
to your system I think this is something
that's fine if you're sort of constantly
working on a project every day or every
week but if you have longer gaps then I
think having fewer dependencies is
actually what makes the development more
sustainable and we do like the fact that
we have more control over how things
work because for example here you need
to integrate with the Jupiter
environment all the stuff around so you
do need a certain level of control of
how the user interface is rendered and
it turns out that the core logic that
that react or all these sort of modern
programming methods for the web what
they what they do is actually pretty
simple
sorry I'm going to show you that I'm
going to show you that the way the
architecture works and for this part I
want to show you the F Serb code first
and then how the same things look in
same thing looks in typescript so this
has really two purposes one is I think
the F sharp version of it is quite clean
and it conveys the idea very well so
I'll show you how to do this and F sharp
to explain how things work and if you're
familiar with with or you can you can
use the F sharp part to make sense of it
and then sort of see how the same thing
works in works in typescript and I think
that the other thing is that the sort of
typescript version will then help you
understand what's going on in F sharp
here so I'm just going to start my
sample project
and I've got all my code here already so
let's just let's just wait until the
backpack server launches so here in F
sharp I'm using fable which is f sharp
to JavaScript compiler that takes my
absorb code produces produces JavaScript
and passes it through all standard
JavaScript things like backpack for for
building and life reloads and this is
running seven oh seven one so right now
I've got a page that says welcome to
counter this is not going to be a super
super inspiring demo I'll just create a
little counter where I'm going to count
the number of clicks on a button so the
way to do this is I have two types that
represent model and event and model is
my state in the application so in my
state I'll just have count and initially
let's start with 0 and then when I'm
rendering it then I'm going to I'm going
to put I can say current count and then
at the add the current count and the
current count is something that comes
from I need some more parentheses from
this state state variable so the way the
system works is that I define what's my
state I define an initial state so my
state has count it's an int initially 0
and then I define a rendering function
that uses this little domain-specific
language for generating HTML and it can
access the state if I save this then I
get current count is 0
and I can add some buttons to increment
and decrement so I'm going to create a
button and this is going to be text plus
one and I'll add a button for minus one
as well if I save this I now get my
buttons and how do you handle events in
this architecture so the idea is that
you define a type for events and here
I'll just define one message which says
update the state and it's going to take
an integer as an argument and that's
going to be plus 1 or minus 1 and in the
user interface you can then trigger
those events so I can say whenever click
happens on the +1 button
I want to trigger the update event with
plus 1 and whenever click happens on the
minus 1 button I'm going to get minus 1
and the the key thing is I now have to
implement this other function called
state called update which takes the
current state and a message and we're
going to pattern match on the message if
this is update by some number then we're
going to return a new state where the
count is the original count plus the
difference so I think this should this
should actually do all I want it let's
see if it if it can count can it count
plus works - works all right so this is
the core the core thing now I want to
make one more change I want to do it so
that the count initially is not started
like you start with a counter that's not
initialized you have to click the start
button and the F sharp way of doing this
is to use the option type so now I'm
saying account can be a number or it can
be
set and initially this is going to be
man indicating this has not been set yet
and in my rendering and I'm going to
save a bit of typing here in my
rendering I'm going to pattern match on
the count and if this has not been set
meaning I haven't started counting yet
I'll generate a pay up page with welcome
to counter and a start button if the
current count has already been stopped
the counting has started I'll generate a
page with
and the start button is going to send a
new type of message which I'm calling
reset and one nice thing in F sharp is
that all those things are are checked so
I get a message here saying in my update
function I'm not handling the risk reset
message so if I get the reset message
then this is the case where I want to
return zero to initialize my counter and
I'm go also going to have to pattern
match on the current count so reset that
ignores the current count but if I'm
ignoring if I'm updating then I need to
get the count and updated by a certain
number and this is this is going to be
set which is indicated by the some case
if i get update but i haven't really
started counting yet this is an invalid
operation i'm just going to ignore it
although you should probably throw an
error message in this case so if i if i
save it i have a counter where i can
start and then i can count so this is
this is all i wanted to show an f-sharp
thank you shut this down and i think
this is really really a nice approach to
implementing reactive web applications
where you're in sort of it's not i
wouldn't necessarily use this if i was
using something with like lots of forms
where there's standard components for
doing that it works really nicely for
this case because we're basically
creating our own user interface and
f-sharp has this really nice way of
modeling modeling domain logic so this
is another example where i'm saying i'm
implementing a to-do list the model is
the list of to-do items a to-do item has
a title and a due day
and what can happen is I can add a new
item or I can reset and in the Elm
architecture you have these two
operations update and render where
update takes the current model and a
message what's what's happened and it
produces the new state new model render
takes mainly the model and produces an
HTML output and it also has this trigger
operation which is this first function
here and that's used for triggering
events so can we do the same thing in
typescript there's a few things that I'm
going to be using so first of all I
really like the way I've sharp type
checks everything and if you're using
typescript then typescript has various
flags that you can turn on for enabling
various security checks or checks in the
type system so there's strict null
checks flag to avoid nulls
and no implicit any to avoid this any
type which means any any JavaScript
value so this is this is really useful
and we've been using that and there's a
flag just strict which terms all these
things on so I'll show you how this how
this works and it turns out that you can
use typescript actually reasonably well
for implementing both the record types
that I was using an f-sharp and these
discriminated unions that I was using
for representing the messages now those
aren't really immutable so here you just
rely on being disciplined about how to
use them and it's it's one thing that we
didn't always do well in our project so
we then occasionally mutate something by
accident and then ended up scratching
our heads for for a half an hour to find
where we did that
so what I want to do now is do basically
exactly the same thing but in pipe
script so I've got the same stub
implemented here and I'll start it
and in this project and I'll I'll send
link to the code the only thing that I'm
not really showing you as this is this
Alma GPS file which is using the the
market library and what the library does
for us is the updating of the back page
updating of the Dom so this is the sort
of standard virtual Dom trick where
we're not really replacing the whole the
whole content of the screen we're just
updating bits there but you could see
that this was this was all my code here
is some why is it 50 lines of code so
I'm not really hiding anything
complicated and I'm just using one
external library and I'll do you exactly
the same thing as I did before in F
sharp so I'll have a type representing
my state called model and I'll have a
type representing my events and then
I'll have a render function which says
welcome to counter and an update
function where I do the update when some
some event happens and I have an initial
state and then I just call my helper to
start the app
so this I thought running on another
port there is s just to show that this
is actually running if I say from
typescript
this should sooner or later reload there
it is let's reload it says welcome from
PI script so I want to recreate the same
thing I did in excerpt so the model this
is this is going to be quite easy
I'll just have count and that's going to
be a number and the more interesting
thing is how do you actually represent
those events so I had two events I had
reset event and the representation you
can use in typescript realize on on two
things
it relies on Union types where you can
say a type is one type or another type
but it also relies on this on this very
interesting trick with singleton types
or um where I can say a resset event has
a kind and the type I'm using here is
it's not string is just a constant
string called reset and a reset event
just doesn't have anything else I also
have update event and this is going to
have a kind update and a number by how
much and then the event is either reset
event or update event so this is really
pretty much the same as the absorb
discriminated Union and we'll see that
this is this is quite interesting when
we use this the way I'm going to do the
rendering well first of all I should I
should do my initialization correctly so
let's start with count equals one hold
on one you can see the biggest problem
for an f-sharp person coming to
typescript is you have to use colons and
multiples
and this bit here is the same kind of
HTML rendering so we're going to render
an h1 with the current count current is
followed by we get the count and convert
that to string so that should should be
a good start
and now I need a button I'm going to
spare you some of my some of my typing
slow typing attempts and copy those two
bits from here so I've got two buttons
and one is the increment button the
other is the decrement button and they
do have they do have all click event
handler where if I click on the button
it will trigger the event now the
interesting thing here is when I'm when
I'm triggering the event this is really
determining that I'm triggering the
update event so this is producing a
value of the update event type and the
interesting thing I need to do here is
do the updating so if I get if I get
well let me first see if it actually
runs so if I save this I do get I do get
current count this one so that works and
my buttons don't do anything yet so how
do I get my buttons to work let's see
and this is the bed this is the this is
the really interesting bit so if you do
EVT dot then you can see that the the
event which is my event has this has
this property called kind and kind is of
type which
this can be two strengths it can be
either the reset string or it can be the
update string now in some cases if this
is if this is update there should also
be a property called by because then
we're specifying whether it's plus one
or minus one how do we access that well
this is the bit where typescript is
doing something quite interesting
because if I say switch over the event
kind I don't think that if the case is
and and actually the editor even knows
this the editor knows that EVT dot kind
can only be two things it can only be
reset or update so if it's reset then
we're going to return a new state where
the count is zero
if this is update then and this is where
things get interesting because if I do
EVT dot I do actually get by in my
autocomplete so how does this work
typescript knows that event can be
either reset event or update event and
it knows that this is determined by the
value of the kind
now if the kind is reset there's nothing
else but if the kind is update there's
this by property here which I can now
access to increment my count so count is
going to be the original count plus by
so with a bit of luck this should now
make my incrementing and decrementing
work seems alright and the one last
thing that I haven't implemented yet is
this this start button so I do have a
improved version of my rendering
function here which that's the same
thing that I was doing in in f-sharp
before so if state dot count is not mal
then I'm counting and I'll render the
current count and do the plus and minus
one button otherwise I'll just say
welcome to counter and we will start
with count being null now
five if I save this then I have the
start button and now I can do counting
now one thing I haven't done here really
is I haven't dealt with these nulls very
nicely so um I just said counts Danelle
but count is actually a number and if I
did not if I wasn't careful
I could I could get various errors
caused by now so this is the default
sort of bad behavior you get you get in
old-school JavaScript but the nice thing
in typescript is that I can read enable
these straight null checks so if I in my
config say straight male chicks on then
suddenly I get a bunch of errors here
like a bunch of errors I get an error
here so this is not the most useful
place for getting my error message the
main issue is that this actually does
I'll sort of
well typescript doesn't infer that this
is model because it's not model it
couldn't be modeled because it model
doesn't allow no so I have to change my
types a little bit and I quite like this
this the way that the typescript handles
mouths because you can say account is a
is of type number or now so you're
explicitly saying you can get mal here
and well if you do that then suddenly in
my update
I can't just access access count and do
calculations with it because it can be
mal so I have to do the same thing which
I did in EPS ARP in F sharp I use
pattern matching on optional values here
I have to say if stable count is not now
then I can do this otherwise I can just
return state and that's all I have to do
to fix it and this is sort of pointing
out a potential issue in my code and you
have to be explicit about about your
your nulls so I do like this strict
option and it's pretty much the same as
what I did before with f-sharp and
option types so option types are sort of
a way of doing the same thing without
having all this extra machinery in the
language now I can be even more strict
and turn on strict strict type checking
and what this does it gives me an error
here so one thing this enabled is that I
now have to explicitly well I'm not
allowed to have to have variables which
will implicitly have a type any so in in
typescript the any type is a very useful
thing for interoperating with JavaScript
because if you don't know what what
object you may get from JavaScript you
just say it's any and you can do
anything you want with it in typescript
you can turn this
and now I have to be explicit about my
types the sad thing is that typescript
doesn't really infer all the types so
here I have to do it manually and I have
to say that trigger is a function which
takes an event I guess I have to say
takes an event and produces unit Boyd
but you have to say you have to call it
somehow EVT so I think all those type
annotations this is something I don't
find very pleasant so that was the
counter demo and the main point here is
really I think this is this is a very
nice architecture and it works quite
well with typescript and here I'm just
sort of implementing things from scratch
because that mode suits suits our
project for for two reasons the user
interface we're building most of it
ourselves so it's a very custom UI
that's one thing second this is
something that's not going to be sort of
updated every single day so we don't
want to rely on the sort of breaking
changes by others so in typescript you
can model what F sharp nose has
discriminated unions using using these
interfaces with singleton types and the
Union constructor and you can put this
nicely with the Elm architectural
operations and the type signatures of
those I think are somewhat painful to
read but it's the same thing as in F
sharp so you have update takes the state
and event and produces a new state
trigger a renderer takes this trigger
operation for notifying the system that
something has happened state and
produces an HTML node so what are the
the interesting reflections I'll
demonstrate this using a few few
examples
so the first example and coming from
from our rattler project is that
Brettler is extensible and you can add
new kinds of cells so we had Python
JavaScript markdown but you can you can
build your own cell with your own user
interface as well and to do that you
have to implement some interface so this
defines a what is the language plug in a
language plug-in defines the language
that's just a string has some editor
which is another object and then it
defines how you parse code how you
evaluate code how you sniff code and how
you bind which is our name for a sort of
step that happens before evaluation
where we construct dependencies so all
those things you have to implement and
in our actual actual system I've got
I've got one example
we're we're implementing a little
language plug-in called merger wear and
this is just a demo it's not it's not
useful for anything practical where the
idea is you have a little little
language that okay all it can do is it
can merge data frames so if I turn this
on and save my files I've got another
instance of Rattler running here as a
standalone thing so this now reloads and
I turned it on and I now have a new cell
type so I can add a merger cell and this
has this is this is using a little while
programming language not even
programming language where you just say
output data frame name and comma
separated list of input data frames so
this is a domain-specific language for
merging merging data frames it's just a
demo and if I evaluate this what happens
is it now merged two of my data frames
if I add the third one then it it merged
three of my data frames so there's
there's a bunch of codes running here in
and the relevant bits is I need to
implement this interface and in my
implementation I decided to just create
a value using the object notation so
this is something I find quite nice you
can you can sort of define interface and
implement that by constructing an object
that has all the required things if I
remove one of the things that is
required then I get an error message
saying you're not you don't have that so
I'm implementing that object here and as
part of the work and this is this is
where the sort of interesting logic
comes in
Rattler works is that all those all
those data frames that I've been merging
they're stored in a component called
datastore and Python or R will put the
data into datastore and when some other
component wants to access that they will
have to fetch it from the datastore and
then the result we put back to the
datastore so here we have some code that
calculates the current value and puts
that into the into the data store and
this is a place where you just
inevitably have any values because
you're working with things that you get
from the web now the other interesting
thing is that this actually well I'm not
I'm not I'm not showing the getting of
the data because that's in a separate
file but I'll get it get back to that so
I think there's few interesting things
that I find quite tricky in typescript
one is this sort of you can you can
often do object-oriented programming
with classes and interfaces and if
you're doing more object-oriented style
which sort of inheritance then you do
want you know you do want to use classes
another thing that you get with classes
is you can actually check whether in a
value is an instance of a class using
this instance of instance of operator
and this does not work with just an
interface it only works with classes and
if you want to have a runtime checks
then you do need that if you but the
sort of object implementations of
interfaces which is what I've been using
give you somewhat lighter syntax there's
somewhat easier to use but they don't
give you this sort of ability to do two
checks so one thing that we've struggled
with occasionally in our case was we
just started with an with an anonymous
interface implementation using the
object like what I'm what I'm showing
here and then for one reason or another
we decided we need to turn this into a
class and it turns out that you can you
can do that but the annoying thing I'm
switching between the two versions is
that pretty much every single bit of
syntax changes so here you do column now
this becomes implements here I say equal
curly bracket now I just say curly
bracket in the code previously I had
columns everywhere now I just have
equals everywhere my function previously
was defined as a attribute which is
implemented using the arrow notation
followed by curly brackets now it's
without that just as a function and the
body the body stays the same so this is
one case where I thought there's there
some pretty crazy inconsistencies
between the two different ways of doing
the same thing now it makes sense
because that's how that's how each other
script works but I think it's this is
one of the examples where the JavaScript
heritage of typescript really means that
doing certain things is quite painful
the way you do constructors in classes
in typescript is the sort of standard
way you define a constructor and in that
you initialize all the fields and do
someone coming from an F sharp
background where F sharp has these
beautiful implicit constructors where
you just as you're defining the type you
take all your arguments and then you
define all your fields switching to the
typescript world where you need to have
explicit constructors
it's just that that's been a mate it's
just it's a tiny thing but if you're
writing a lot of classes you'll end up
wasting a lot of time now there's a few
places where where I managed to bring
the type system or break where the type
system sort of does
things according to the necessities of
the JavaScript environment which aren't
very pleasant so one of those is when
you're when you're using fetching some
data from HTTP always get response or
the data which is of type any and then
if you're not careful you can very very
easily get into trouble by sort of
propagating that any value somewhere
else in your code and causing all sorts
of troubles and you can remove some of
those places where this error can happen
by using the strict mode and if you're
if you're doing the same thing in F
sharp there's I think F sharp type
providers are one of the nice nice
features that can help you with that
when you can sort of strongly type your
responses but if you're using Fable if F
sharp you'll just this is a place where
you will easily notice that this is a
problematic place so you have to define
some type explicitly or you just won't
be accessed won't be able to access it
that easily so that's where sort of F
sharp makes things harder for you but I
think it's actually a price worth paying
because it just removes quite a few
errors and I do have one one very
curious example so this is a place where
the fact that pipes rip is still just
the JavaScript runtime underneath thus
cause a few few surprising issues so
this is a this is a
bit of code that is actually pretty much
based on what we had we have this
interface representing a variable a
variable has the name and we have an
object which we're using as a as a
lookup table you can sort of use the
square brackets to index into it and
it's basically just a map or lookup
table we're given a variable name you'll
get the variable and and I have a little
function which returns the length of the
name of a variable so it takes the scope
which is our variables or data frames in
scope the name of the variable and it
says if this variable is not undefined
then return the length of the name
otherwise return minus one and this is
this is even in the strict mode so this
can't be no and the question is can this
ever fail because because the name is
undefined
so in my type name is a string it can't
be undefined otherwise you'd have to say
name on string or undefined but it turns
out because this is underneath
JavaScript if you just call this and use
empty lookup table and to string as the
name of the variable then this breaks
and your code crashes because this
lookup is just the object lookup of
JavaScript and all objects in JavaScript
have to string that's the method that
you can use for converting those to
string so this is not undefined but it's
not actually as our type requires a
variable so it's a it's a function it's
not a variable and this is I think a
case where the fact that we're building
on on JavaScript typescript can remove
some of those quirks but not all and
this was this was a case where we
release this sounds pretty arbitrary but
we really did spend an
debugging this issue because we did have
a variable called stew string the the
last bit I wanted to talk about is some
of the things that I didn't find
particularly elegant in typescript but
that were not really a major issue so
this is mostly about the syntax and
types read inherits the JavaScript
syntax which is really sort of designed
for not necessarily functional style of
programming so this is perfectly
expected that's the price you have to
pay when you want to use typescript in a
functional way and I'll this is again
based on an experience of writing a
piece of the the Rattler system where
one of the one of the really sort of
nice interesting innovative pieces of
data science to length we've got are
these guy assistants which are tools for
semi automated data wrangling and I'll
show you what this is so I'm going to
open another demo and you can go to
rattler not orc and play with this later
on your own so I've got one example here
where I'm downloading some data on air
traffic accidents which is actually
originally coming from Eurostat and the
way the data is structured is that you
have a row representing accidents
related to all airplanes that were
registered in a particular country where
the accident happened in a particular
country so for example here this would
be a road that represents accidents that
happened to aircrafts registered in
Austria that happened in Cyprus and it's
very sparse one of the issue with the
data though is that they also include
aggregates so there's there's
some rows that represent the total for
the whole EU and you think that is quite
tricky and what I can do is I can say I
want to use an AI assistant for outlier
detection on my data set and this will
create a cell with custom user interface
where I can just run the AI assistant
and then ask it how do you recommend I I
fix this code and the assistant says you
should add a filter where see wretches
is not u28 and also geo is not u28
so it looks at my data and finds the
outliers and and it recommends that I
add certain filters and I can see what
rows it actually removed so this is a
tool where if you're cleaning data it
can help you with some of the typical
boring tasks and in the implementation
of this there's a few things that I
found quite annoying one is that
sometimes you have two ways of defining
a function you can you can do this using
the sort of lambda syntax which works in
certain contexts like when you're
passing the function as an argument so
here I'm defining a function that takes
a list of AI assistants and generates an
editor where the editor has a certain
initialization code now this is written
using lambda function but if I need to
change it to an explicit function then
again I go through this process of
making so many tiny tweaks in the syntax
so here in the function notation you
just say curly bracket return and then
you return something in the other
notation
you have to say arrow and then you don't
need return but if this starts with
curly brackets then you need extra
parentheses around because otherwise the
interpret the parser will treat it as a
code block
another thing that I find I find quite
tedious is in the code that constructs
these HTML blocks using the H notation
in in typescript I end up with a lot of
helper definitions and then I end up
with sort of one messy condition that
says depending on the state to do this
or this or this and in F sharp this was
actually this is this is one thing that
can be handled quite nicely with list
comprehensions where I just define a
list and then I say yield this user
interface element or this element or
this element so you can embed quite a
lot of logic in this code that
constructs lists so - - to wrap up
so I talked that I talked about F sorry
about typescript from the perspective of
an observed person and and also from the
perspective of a very specific project
where our project sort of is
long-running not very not very sort of
ongoing all the time it's reimplemented
a plain user interface from scratch and
typescript worked quite nicely with this
Elm architecture and I did like the fact
that we sort of implemented that
ourselves had a nice control over that
tight grip isn't really designed for
functional style so some of the things
will end up being ugly and in some
places it's trying to be JavaScript in
some places it's not and this often
leads to random surprises like this -
string thing
would I would I sort of when would I
prefer f-sharp when would I prefer
typescript so I'm obviously biased here
as an F sir person I always choose F
sharp but I was working in a team where
this was a team decision and we did did
go for typescript how did how do the two
compare so if you're using EPS are
pour'd about with fable then I think the
remarkable thing is that F Serb has this
functional core which is safe and clean
and works and the way fable compiles
this is that it avoids most of the trade
although all those sort of messiness of
JavaScript so you have the core language
which works nicely is predictable is
understandable and then there's the
extra integration curve which inevitably
has to make trade-offs typescript
supports many different styles including
sort of object-oriented and functional
and it doesn't really hide JavaScript
it's sort of JavaScript is one of the
styles that's a typescript some supports
and unlike an EPS are where the core and
the integration is quite clearly
separated I felt like in typescript this
is not so much the case so you always
end up mixing different different bits
and you can do it well or you can do it
not well and it's really hard to sort of
figure out what is well what is not so
to go back to my to my meditating
meditating kittens a lot
who knows that absorb is the right
choice for everything all the time I
think the important things here from the
talk where I was actually actually quite
sort of pleased with using typescript in
the way we used it I'm using the sort of
plain L mich elvish architecture you
have to be very disciplined and you're
not really you'll you'll end up using
typescript in a way that's not obvious
so you
I sort of thought if we go for top for
typescript people won't have to learn
too much that's not really the case if
you want to do functional programming in
typescript you have to learn functional
programming in typescript I'm just like
if you want to do F sharp you have to
learn that sharp so that that learning
is still there
typescript in a functional way is really
different language than typescript in
the JavaScript way and a lot of these
decisions really depend on the project
context so you always have to have to
use your use your judgment that's all I
wanted to say and I'll have a look at
the questions now so thanks for tuning
in and for sticking to the end all right
question is there a reason you're using
interface as opposed to type system
seems to me that the interface is just a
reference to I have to move my window
here haha to Microsoft's inclination
200p yeah I think that this this bit is
something I found sort of confusing as
well like there's there's so many
different ways of doing things that I
just ended up using interface because I
think that's the first thing I was I was
able to get to work and I don't really
have a good good answer to that it's
true that it's true that this this might
be the case where typescript just sort
of inherits a lot of different styles
and some of them are more Oh like if you
use oo you might end up with classes and
interfaces if if you're using different
style you'll you'll end up more with
with types so there's no there's no good
good reason for this it's just a random
decision based on what I got what I was
able to go to get to work easily for
what I wanted
but yeah if you look at some of my type
definitions sort of earlier on there's
there's cases where you need to say type
there's cases where it doesn't really
matter like here this has to be a type
because I'm defining a type alias but
the way you define the way you define
the record types I don't really know if
there's sort of subtle differences all
right any more questions I don't think
there's there's any other question here
so I don't think anyone's anyone's
joining life on zoom so if that's if
that's it then thanks again for joining
and I'll post all the code including
most importantly the to F sharp and
typescript comparisons sort of side by
side of the Amish architecture which i
think is a fun thing that people can
play with later thank you
you